democracy in action radhiya jrb founded
the independent electoral lists called
citizens and we participate she's
brought her supporters to the city of
Arianna to campaign the second-hand
market here is a popular spot where many
women shop Tunisian women come to this
market from the surrounding areas
I know Tunisian women are decision
makers and women should support each
other that's why we came here today to
make sure these women know that they are
important to enable them to improve
their situation taking part in the
elections and being able to choose a
list that is headed by women
very few of Tunisia's electoral lists
can claim that only about 14% of more
than 1,500 taking part in the poll have
a woman at the top Bosma how far is one
she heads to newzeas democratic and
social union and she's calling on voters
to choose her list in Sunday's poll I
cannot give you a Venezuela visual
dilemma the number of women who take
part in political life in Tunisia is
very low and women are not politically
active despite their Orbis ability I
think women are just as competent as men
can be and even more so than men
sometimes statistics say that the
percentage of girls who are successful
in school is higher than that for male
pupils
however they remain less well
represented and they are discriminated
against in decision-making positions Ali
ABI Majid ELISA
the Tunisian League of Women Voters is
backing kapowee
is aims to empower female candidates and
enable their participation in political
life
Vaness Bell mother she had unica women
candidates are subjected to political
pressure from different political
parties and they need fostering and
protecting even the government does not
really take into consideration the
principle of equality between women and
men that's despite the fact that we have
highly competent and honest women in
public life radhiya jrb is at ease on
the campaign trail she doesn't have any
problem sitting with men in cafes and
discussing politics but she's convinced
that tunisia is still a patriarchal
society and thinks most people tend to
vote for men rather than female
candidates and there's a sense here that
the political parties campaigns and
slogans calling for women's empowerment
and participation are mere words many of
the female candidates standing in 2019
fear their chances may be worse than in
previous elections odw reporter and
North Africa analyst ayah ibrahim is
here with me in the studio to talk about
all of this hello to you aya so
according to some political analysts
around 80 percent of Tunisians don't
trust in the established parties why is
that so high why do they not trust them
my impression is that most voters feel
like they've given established parties
enough enough of a chance this is the
third legislative election since the
outbreak of the Arab Spring in 2011
Tunisia was the country where this wave
of revolutions started and throughout
throughout these two two parliamentary
periods the deep-seated reasons of why
the Arab Spring happened in Tunisia
haven't been solved so this election is
happening against the backdrop of high
prices soaring prices youth unemployment
which is estimated to be up to 30% in
some rural areas and 15% in some of the
cities and also inflation and corruption
and from some of the people that I've
spoken to they feel that the political
parties have been too busy discussing
personnel issues rather than coming up
with effective
see in the past some nine years and
there they're losing their patience with
them alright we just mentioned it during
the presidential poll which was just a
few weeks ago voters really punished the
established parties can we expect the
same to happen this time around we were
talking before the show opinion polls
are not allowed in Tunisia opinion polls
are not allowed in Tunisia but as you
said you know this is this is a very
historically unique a moment for Tunisia
where presidential elections had to
happen prematurely because the previous
president passed away and you know if
this if the trend continues if the
results if the results of the first
round of the presidential elections are
any indication independents are likely
to win big they have also made quite
headway in some local elections which
we've seen previously no party is
expected to make the 109 seats in
parliament majority to form a government
which means like as as with the previous
government they're a coalition
government is to be expected this will
be difficult coalition making is
difficult in any part of the world and
in a place like Tunisia is likely to
lead take more time and lead to more
frustration but independents are
expected to make big gains as well all
right so it may not be easy to form a
government especially if coalition's are
involved and yet Tunisia is the only
country that has seen democratic reforms
since the Arab Spring I had just how
Democratic is the country today to just
certainly a democracy and unlike other
countries in the region like Egypt for
example Tunisia has managed to avoid
descending back into military rule so
it's certainly also a a sieve it's a
civilian-led democracy which is is is a
huge accomplishment I mean one might
look at the elections in Tunisia and
they certainly have a lot of problems
but I think you know this this kind of
discontent with established parties and
moving towards independent parties is
actually a sign of political maturity
for Tunisians
they are unhappy and they're registering
their dissatisfactions through the polls
the results are likely to be difficult
but that is part of a building of
democracy and teachers also the only
country that has evolved its political
system they now have this mixed party
system
as opposed to a presidentially dominated
system which had had before the Arab
Spring all-righty W is ie brahim always
great to hear your insights thank you so
much